食べ始めたら大雨
雷もあった時代でしじきボーンってでも
やんだ
でも昨日本当に食べ始めってその瞬間に始まったからちょっと
あのー、ドキドキしちゃいましたよ
明日台風大丈夫かね
水曜日っていう今のところ予報
お帰りになると台風の
ニュース見てない
台風が来る?
台風が来るけど
もう来てますよ近くに
もう来てるんだよ
前に釣ったら見るよ
あんだけできない間になって
今どこらへんですか?
もうすぐ関東に突撃するらしい
明日ぐらい
そうなんですか?
なんか本当に今回はちょっと上を通りそうな感じですよ
いわしから西に
そうなん
予報を見るとね
倉田さんたちのお点が終わる日の午前中らしいんですね
この辺の雨が
ビルと天がこう
開けていくっていう
なんか今んとこの予報なので
なんとなくそれを見ながら
帰り道は大丈夫かな?っていうね
想像してるんですけど
帰り道は大丈夫だけど
開尾中雨なんですね
あ~そうかそうかそうか
それは皆さんの足が
確かに
これたち明日行けるよね
私たち明日行こうと思って
あっそのとき
確かに
大体やっぱりこう
例年
決まった顔ぶれというか
来られる方
まあそうですね
あの
まあ東京から来る子
結構僕が教えてた学生とか
うんうんうん
まあ乗るついでに来たり
この近く乗るとかあるんで
あ~そうか
あの
生徒市牧場っていうところで
外場して
寄ってくれた子たちがいますね
うーん
山の中歩いて
歩いてって?
馬で?
馬で
へ~
もうできますよ
あそうなんですか?
うんうん
いや
なんかちょっと関心ありますけど
なんかいきなり
何も知らないで乗るには
あの
あまりにも準備ができてない感じ
でもそういうのってやっぱり
童馬クラブに
行くことが
始める